okay Island I'm so sorry but I'm gonna
interrupt you and you're just once again
to take us to Joe Biden who is speaking
to your supporters unless listening to
campaign
[Applause]
and we're to where when you got to Super
Tuesday be over well it may be over for
the other guy
[Applause]
tell that to the folks in Virginia
[Applause]
see
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
and maybe even Massachusetts as suppose
[Applause]
and we're still waiting for Texas in
California few other small states to
come in buzz I'm good
so I'm in a report we are very much
alive
[Applause]
and make no mistake about it this
campaign I will send Donald Trump
packing this campaign is taking off join
us for those folks listen go to Joe
Biden comm signup volunteer contribute
if you can we need you we want you and
there's a place where this campaign
people are talking about a revolution we
started a movement we've increased
turnout the turnout turnout for us that
can deliver us to a moment where we can
do extraordinary extraordinary things
look our agenda is bold that's
progressive it's a vision where health
care is affordable and available to
everybody in America where big drug
prices down under control or no more
surprise billing access to hospitals and
rural areas the world's urban areas
access to care a bold vision we missed
billions of dollars to find and I
promise you cures for cancer Alzheimer's
and diabetes standing up to a meeting
the NRA the gun manufacturers
[Applause]
and leading the world to take on the
extra sense of that of climate change
I'm gonna start by rejoining an outfit I
helped put together the Paris climate
Accord and we're gonna move away a
country where quality of education will
not depend on your zip code but a triple
funding for low-income school district
providing raises for teachers full-time
school for three four and five years old
and increasing exponentially the
prospects of their success free
Community College variety credentials
for every job the 21st century
[Applause]
and significant reduction in the cost of
going to college and your student debt
if you volunteer you pay nothing
oops we can do this let's get something
straight
Wall Street didn't build this country
you built this country class built this
country and unions built the middle
class and then average wake up from the
thread
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
birthday
we're gonna do the bed class are getting
clobbered the mill class getting
clobbered so many people neighbors to
Jill and Val and I grew up in so every
they're getting hurt they're badly hurt
and guess what they're the places we
come from many of you come from it's
where we raised the people they're the
reason why I'm running there's a reason
why I'm a Democrat in the first place
[Music]
these are people we'll build our bridges
repair our roads keep our water safe who
teach our kids look who race into
burning buildings to protect other
people who grow our food build our cars
pick up our garbage our streets veterans
dreamers single moms and by the way
every dreamer have hope because I'm
coming and you're not going anywhere
and we're at a private pathway a pathway
for 11 million citizens if the other
guide voted for me I don't should get
into that I won't get going look the
iron workers are still workers the
Boilermakers the plumbers the electric
work these are the people that been
forgotten I agree with you man look the
people Trump forgot the people I will
never forgotten I will always remember
folks that's what we need an economy
that rewards work not just wealth
reestablishes the middle class and this
time brings everybody along everybody
regardless of the race their ethnicity
whether their gender their disabilities
economics that Democrats and publicly
depends every strike look like we did in
South Carolina like we did across
America today
like we'll do on our all the way to the
White House look that's why I was so
proud yesterday being embraced by a me
go [ __ ] are we won Minnesota because
Amy global charm
and we're doing well in texted because
of better allure and that's why that's
why I was so proud so incredibly proud
to have mayor Pete's endorsement as well
[Applause]
there's a man of character intellect
encouraged and by the last proud to be
endorsed by Jim Clyburn man he is
something else
look our campaign reflects the diversity
of this party in this nation and that's
how it should be because we need to
bring everybody along everybody we want
to nominate who will beat Donald Trump
but also also keep Mansi Pelosi and
Speaker of the House went back to United
States Senate but that's as you want
join us and they want a nominee who's a
Democrat a lifelong Democrat a proud
Democrat an obama/biden Democrats
look this all starts with revival of
decency and honour and character Trump
has Flair has fanned the flames of hate
and sought to divide us he's insulted
demonized and actually just the way he
talks about people he has not a single
sense of empathy he doesn't have any
compassion no regard for the values that
made this country who we are not the way
you were raised by your moms and dads he
looks at honesty and decency and respect
and he views it as a sign of weakness he
doesn't believe that we're the beacon to
the world he doesn't believe we're all
part of something bigger than ourselves
that's why I've said from the moment I
announced for this candidacy we
literally in the battle for the soul of
America folks
witi means u19 America not sowing seeds
of division and anger and hate we got a
beat Donald Trump but we will but we
can't become like him we can't have a
never-ending war between the parties
where the president could fight but may
no make no mistake about I can fight but
look we need as badly as badly
someone who could heal look just look
what we did we passed Obamacare what
President Obama and I did saving the
American automobile industry or what we
did to pass the Violence Against Women
Act and what that bus not enough this is
just a start we need a president can
heal the country as well and that is
what I will do as your president I
promise you
it's about reliving delivering real
results for you your family and the
community it's not about me Jill or
Valerie it's about you it's about our
families
it's a paraphrase the English poet
Robert Brown and he said our reach
should exceed our grasp and my reach
does exceed our grasp because there's no
doubt of my mind we can grasp whatever
we reach for ladies and gentlemen I
quoted an English poet but let me call
the real poet now an Irish poet Seamus
Heaney who wrote a poem called accurate
Roy here's what he says and I believe
this to the bottom of my being
he said history says don't hope on this
side of the grave but then once in a
lifetime
the longed-for tidal wave of justice
rises up and hope and history rhyme we
can make hope and history rhyme because
what we say there's nothing we can't do
this is about the future it's not about
the past about our children and our
grandchildren it's about leading this
country and leading the world once again
folks we just have to remember who we
are my lord this is the United States of
America this time for America to get
back up
and once again fight for the proposition
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men and women are
created equal endowed by the creator
with certain inalienable rights we said
so often in school we don't realize how
profound it is we've never lived up to
those words but until this president
we've never walked away from it ladies
and gentlemen I believe with every fiber
of my being that's who we are
so let's get back up we are a decent
brave resilient people we can believe
again but we are we are better than this
moment we are better than this president
so get back up and take back this
country the United States America
there's not a single thing we can't do
god bless you and may God protect our
troops thank you thank you thank you
Joe Biden the former vice-president
addressing the supporters in Los Angeles
California it's been a very good night
for him he was briefly interrupted by
animal rights protest protesters during
that speech in California but unfazed
Joe Biden he is in a pretty good mood
wired even I would say from what we
heard there he's had a good night too no
doubt he's won a couple of states and
still looking for a few victories as
we've heard there